health officials in Georgia are looking
into whether the flu killed a
five-year-old boy Eli snook died on
Saturday his parents say he suffered an
infection in his brain
on Tuesday the virus killed 15 year old
Georgia high school student kira Molina
mark Strassmann is at Children's
Healthcare of Atlanta
Eggleston hospital with more on this
story mark good morning
a good morning at last count Georgia has
had 37 flu deaths the state's single flu
season record is 59 and health officials
expect a top bat soon and behind each of
those deaths is a family story like this
he was the son I've always wanted I've
always wanted a baby boy that five year
old boy was Eli snook his parents Lyoto
and Aaron's say he came down with a high
fever nearly two weeks ago they took him
to Urgent Care near their home in
Marietta where they say he was diagnosed
with the flu and prescribed antibiotics
and the antiviral medication Tamiflu
after he got well from the flu a few
days later he got sick again
Eli tested negative for the flu this
time but doctors noticed a rash across
his body and sent him to Children's
Healthcare of Atlanta see his face and
he's like he's fighting his jaw and his
arm goes in he starts having seizures he
was placed in a medically induced coma
while doctors performed a cat scan and a
spinal tap but the virus had spread to
his brain his brain swelled past the
point of no return and they told us that
he was brain dead
nurses surrounded Eli at his bedside
while his parents prayed for a miracle
[Music]
unfortunately the Lord took him home so
and it was Saturday at 10 o'clock Eli's
parents say he did not have a flu shot
dr. daniel salinas is chief medical
officer at Children's Healthcare of
Atlanta the best line of defense to
prevent influenza is to get a vaccine if
your kids are sick don't take any
chances you can't really know these
things it just happens
the snooks buried their son on Wednesday
and because of the flu Children's
Healthcare of Atlanta had seen record
numbers of patients at all three of its
hospitals at all seven of its urgent
care facilities John Mark thanks